if we have enough tests right now for
everyone to go into Phase one why is the
governor of Maryland having to get half
a million tests from South Korea I don't
know what the governor of Maryland is
doing in South Korea but there is excess
capacity every day if he wanted to send
30 or 40,000 tests to LabCorp and quest
that that could be done that could be
done tomorrow that they needed to start
to take up their testing capacity and
make it adequate I think I think we're
seeing all across the country that in
the states that have been hardest hit
their capacity not only our capacity
they're testing far far exceed South
Korea and they've been able to do that
on a relatively straightforward basis I
don't know what the governor of Maryland
we talked to him today he didn't bring
that up today we were on the governor's
call today we spoke to Governor Hogan
today I'll follow up because I heard
there was an announcement today about
that he had acquired some tests from
overseas maybe we can put the slide back
up that showed the number of facilities
just in the state of Maryland and part
of our process and I don't know when the
governor placed the order from South
Korea wouldn't wouldn't begrudge him or
his health officials for ordering tests
but the the capacity of all the
different laboratories and a number of
machines that are across Maryland's part
of what we were communicating today
including federal facilities NIH is in
Maryland there's Department of Defense
facilities and what we assured the
governor then and we sure doll the
governors that will open up all of those
facilities